okay let's uh hear from a few more folks
via discord you can join the discord at
davidpakman.com discord
let's try overseas again why don't we go
to
scott from scotland uh what's going on
scott
scott from scotland you are muted you
have to unmute yourself in order for me
to hear you
my apologies my friend do you hear me
well i do
fantastic so a relatively uh
i don't want to say it's a minor point
but maybe not high on the list of
priorities
is legal immigration into the us and
i kind of speak from first-hand
experience here i was i was mid-move
um with work to the us last march when
the the coveted situation kicked off
uh and now we find ourselves in a kind
of a precarious and
uh non-moving position and so i know
that president trump is obviously
focused on
illegal immigration but he also did a
pretty good job of decimating legal
immigration as well through the various
presidential orders he put in place
yes and the last of which expired at
midnight on march the 31st
which he enacted just before new year's
new year's day
um so in theory the presidential orders
have disappeared for the most part for
the kind of legal immigration bans
but what we're finding and this is
something our work attorneys are
struggling with is that embassies and
u.s consulates around the world
are still refusing to see people or
offer appointments or
even just say when they're going to
start resuming services so
i just curious from your perspective
where do you see legal immigration going
under this new administration and do you
think it will improve do you think
i don't know maybe clamp down on it and
kind of readjust the system where do you
i don't see a clamp down what what
you're describing is not unique to the
united states i have i have
friends that are dealing with this in
different places uh i have a friend
that's in the middle of
uh getting portuguese residency
through a so-called golden visa program
and
it's just it's taking forever uh i have
um another friend who's in the middle of
getting israeli citizenship
all of these systems are just slowed
down and i think that
it's i as the pen as we get out of the
pandemic hopefully over the next six to
12 months
a lot of these uh bureaucratic
nightmares will become
slightly less nightmarish but the
question of policy is a different one i
think in the immediate things are just
going to go back to the way they were
before the pandemic
policy is going to be dealt with later
yeah that makes a lot of sense i do know
that biden
and his administration were potentially
looking at kind of changes to the h1
uh lottery system in particular and just
changing how that
how that goes but i guess it'll be
interesting to see how that plays out
over the coming months
no doubt about it and so but so now are
you are you no longer
trying to move to the us no we're still
in progress i'm i'm living in a
half-packed house and have been since
last march i had an embassy appointment
um last march and then they
postponed it and again and again we put
in an exemption request
for national security exemptions i work
in areas related to national security
and the consulate um rejected it without
even reading it so
wow we're in a bit of a stage a strange
stay at the moment but still very much
pursuing trying to get things sorted out
all right well i hope things are
normalized for you
thank you david all right scott from
scotland thank you so much for the call
we are speaking to folks via discord as
we often do
you can find the discord at
davidpakman.com
discord that's the way to do it
let's go to how about aj
in oregon or as the former president
said it
oregon aj what's going on
hey david can you hear me just barely aj
we and we've got you cranked up and it's
just
it's just a whisper how about now is
that better
barely barely wha what's going on let's
see if we can get your question out
um i was wondering if you had a magic
wand to
enact any policy regarding police reform
what would you change and why i have a
whole video clip about this where i lay
out about eight to ten different points
and it includes uh training social work
training
for police officers uh we talk about
body cameras we talk about civilian
review boards that actually work
a national bad actors database uh
there's about eight to ten different
points i i've outlined it pretty
pretty specifically and um there's
probably even more that that could be
added to it but definitely check that
clip out it's on youtube
okay um but uh not anything
specifically out of those like there
isn't anything
uh that you would place above uh all the
others
uh no i didn't prioritize the list i
mean it's a list of about eight to ten
things i did i didn't rank them if
that's the question
okay um i guess more specifically i was
wondering
about the uh uh body cameras uh
specifically
and uh their impact uh
because i noticed a lot of times with
these uh
issues with police brutality uh we're
really dependent on body cam to get a
unbiased
sort of recording of the event
yeah my general view is i like the idea
of body cameras
it shouldn't be so easy for them to just
not
record at exactly the key moment and
then you hear about oh the footage is
missing the camera didn't turn on
i know that there are some
small studies that claim complaints for
use of force
went up when body cameras were put in
place and a lot of right wingers will
point to that and say
cc we don't need body cameras at the at
the macro level everything i've read is
that use of force complaints
go down when body cameras are are put in
place
so i think there's still details to sort
out but from everything i've read i'm in
favor of body cameras
and uh just the last thing on that so
would you
in the course of events where a body
camera is turned off or not available
would you hold the the police department
accountable for that missing footage if
body camera reform was put into place
where they required everyone to
uh record uh the course of events
i don't know how you manage that because
there's a big difference between
the officer deliberately turns the
camera off which really it's
it's a question whether they should even
have the ability to do that
or everything's recorded and then in the
cloud but somehow
the footage disappears to
just genuinely there's a technical issue
you need a system for
managing all of those different
circumstances i don't know exactly what
that system is right now
all right thank you very much i i love
the show
all right there is aj barely audible but
we were able to make it work
always a good thing